As you know, we're all
losing it a little bit.
Times are tough, so many things
are screwed up at the moment.
Here in California we're
dealing with fires.
Terrible fires.
I mean it's much worse
in Northern California,
but still I gotta tell you the air quality
is pretty bad here in Los Angeles too.
Now a lot of friends of mine
that live in other parts
of the country have been asking me
how bad is the air quality
in LA at the moment?
And I thought, why not show you?
Why don't I demonstrate
how bad the air is?
It's a lot, lot more convincing
than just telling you.
So here's what I'm gonna do.
I've got a clean bleached
white towel right here.
I'm gonna hold it outside in the LA air
and shake it around for just
a second and show you.
(door closing)
That's how bad it is.
Wow that is really something.
Yeah, that was quite a demonstration
of our air quality here in LA.
Informative just not really very funny.
Well that's okay.
We can always just cut
to a video of old people
working out to generic heavy metal.
Good idea, Andy.
(upbeat music)